[Music]
welcome to the session just after lunch
I think people will be trickling in here
because some of them got lunch late but
hopefully we'll see a stream of people
coming in soon so this is the session
and free inference and instant training
breakthroughs and implications and we
have a stellar set of speakers here
today
Martha and I are chairing this session
we're just going to you know set the
stage introduce the speakers and you
know hear from them so you know in this
session
our aim is to take the blinders off and
fire the imagination of the systems in
machine learning community much of the
community has focused on sort of
speeding up training making it more
efficient you know making inference as
cheap as possible
and most of the work has focused on deep
neural networks we want to we want to
ask the question if all these problems
were solved what should we be looking at
next you know so we we want to do this
at various levels algorithmic level
hardware level you know what what new
hardware should we be considering and
see the frameworks and applications what
are the new applications that we should
be considering and not just you know the
standard image classification our
translation applications that have been
driving this field for the past couple
of years and so in this context we have
four speakers here today if you if you
want to look at the universities they
represent CMU MIT Berkeley and Stanford
and MSR too recently you know five
organizations among four speakers more
importantly they're all experts in ml
theory in algorithms systems hardware
and applications and so we are very very
grateful that they're here today to
share their thoughts with us I like
might I introduce our first speaker
so first speaker is Mike Jordan Michael
Jordan who's the P Hongshan
distinguished professor in the
Department of Electrical Engineering and
computer science and the department of
statistics at the University of
California at Berkeley professor Jordan
is one of the leading forces in the
machine learning community kind of it's
a broad statement but it's actually true
across a lot many many different areas
of machine learning he's known for his
pivotal work in a broad set of areas
bridging cap additional statistical
cognitive and biological services
sciences in particular his work has been
kind of central instead of understanding
the statistical foundations of machine
learning in addition to developing
algorithms and a lot of downstream work
so without further ado here's professor
Michael John okay hi did you get my mic
on now okay so I gather this is a
systems focused crowd so I will have
that in mind my overall message is gonna
be that you know machine learning is in
great growth mode right now it's not one
thing it's a whole bunch of different
kinds of related challenges and so think
about not trying to build you know the a
single database or a UNIX or something
like one tool that solves all problems
in the field there's really more like
tools and so think about someone who
built houses they have a screwdriver and
they have a hammer and they have a saw
and all that and that hadn't changed
over centuries and it's not gonna change
so there's not be one tool this is a
bunch of tools so I have a lot of
respect for systems people I did and I
really want to continue the partnership
which is emerging in fact when I first
went to Berkeley I was coming in as a
machine learning person this is 1998 and
they said well that means you're in the
AI group and I said no I know nothing
about AI and I don't really care I don't
want to build artificial humans that's
not interesting what I want to partner
with is the systems people because they
got a perspective that I think is I
really respect and I want to learn more
about it and I think there was where the
power is gonna be and they continue to
wanted to label me AI over the years and
I've never worked on vision robotics and
I don't again I don't really care I
should say this on a video but I really
care about engineering systems that you
know really change the world it really
large-scale it move data around and all
that
if it has a vision or movement in it
that's fine but it's not my main focus
alright so in fact my perspective on
what's happened in the last say 23 years
is a bit different from the story
usually here that it's all about neural
nets and computer vision so I think
first of all and then you know 20 years
ago it was about the backend fraud
detection was really really important in
the history of machine learning it
really worked and it really change the
business model for Amazon and a lot of
other in the bank's we wouldn't have
Amazon today if they hadn't be able to
solve it with random forests actually
you know early classification systems
supply chain management how do you have
an Amazon if you can't get all the
pieces together to build all the parts
for a billion product to serve hundreds
of millions of people right well you
model all of that with machinery and
that was done back then so after all
those systems had been built this was
partly systems building they had random
forests really built as really good
systems people started think about well
can we turn that onto the front end can
we have humans their data in the loop
can we build recommendation systems and
and so on so forth so I think that was
what happened next and I think what
we're in right now is really what I
would call in to end and you know it's
not that there's been a revolution in
the technology and yes there's a lot of
data and all that so in some domains
that's that's kind of impressive but
it's not that different what it really
is that we have some end-to-end
capabilities now you cuz you can build
almost as a commodity a speech
recognition system and it's an Indian
system it takes in the waveform and
outputs you know something like like
text it doesn't solve the problem but
it's a useful commodity for all kinds of
other things and similarly with vision
problems and so on and so forth so
Indian is both good and bad
it allows you to build a whole commodity
on the other hand it couples everything
together in a really complicated way and
it makes it hard to actually build
systems around those kind of
capabilities so I don't think it's the
model going forward so I think what's
missing right now is actually what we're
seeing emerging is the the kind of
economic perspective of you you make
intelligence systems by having lots of
kind of dumb local decisions in a market
with bidding and pricing and all that
and out of that starts to emerge
intelligence so first of all I don't
like the word intelligence I've said
this and lots of talks but because we
don't have it we don't understand it and
we're not we're not really building it
into our agents and all that they're not
intelligent they're taking in data and
mimicking what they see in the data
right and if we're ever gonna get
intelligence it's gonna have to have
some economic principles because that's
you know a system that brings all the
food into San Francisco every day
to have every person in every restaurant
have all the food they need at the right
place in the right time that's an
amazingly intelligent system but as you
know it's no there's no intelligence in
any point in that system everybody's
just thinking about should I bring
another head of lettuce into a
particular you know such a street
address okay so that's for me what's
happening
now I wrote an op-ed recently and this
kind of talk is inspired by that op IDI
if you haven't read that read that I
would love to have you read it I do
think that it's important to start to
use this word AI in a more sensible way
it's being used as an intellectual
wildcard in my view whenever anybody
does understand what they're really
talking about they say AI and I should
same I think Mark Zuckerberg has done
that better than anybody sitting in
front of Congress saying AI whenever he
didn't know what else to say and I just
I just don't I think we need to move
beyond the usage of the phrase in that
way all right so it was originally
McCarthy and these others who had this
inhuman imitative prosperity would it be
interesting and fun challenging to make
a computer act like a human so let's try
to imitate the human I don't think
that's what actually happened over the
last 50 years I don't think we've done
that I don't think we can imitate humans
at all but what's really happens we
built i eight systems we built systems
that augment human intelligence search
engines intelligent translation and
understory into translation and so on
augmented tell adjust that will continue
and it uses data and it uses actions and
it uses models and neural ants or
whatever you want to do that but I think
the bigger picture which are seen
emerging is what I've been calling hi I
again know this is invented by me just
kind of trying to put a highlight on it
it's Internet of Things meets data
analysis and statistics and decision
making so not just taking in data and
crunching it but making large numbers of
federated decisions in of context of
large numbers of agents hundreds of
thousands of agents simultaneously doing
things that's what we're seeing emerging
and that's not the classical AI
perspective you have one agent making a
decision with all the data it has and
maybe making a sequence at best and the
real world is a hundred thousand agents
making a bunch of correlated decisions
which can be good or bad like the
financial system or the medical system
or the transportation or so that's the
world we should have be having more
intelligence in and we're not really
thinking enough about that okay so let
me just actually skip this slide I'm
just sort of saying about I don't think
with humanity any value we're not as far
along as everyone seems to think
even envision you know the systems work
pretty well with pictures on the
internet they don't work well when you
got in the real world you can train them
up with huge amounts of labels and hue
much of effort and so like you know
Tesla is doing that to build
self-driving cars and that's fine you
can probably do something in that
particular niche but we don't have
systems that really understand the
visual world the way we understand the
verbs and the nouns in the in the world
not just a picking out a few things and
images and so it's a great field
computer vision and it's not over it's
gonna be decades before its we start to
get somewhere with it so we're not there
yet
and that's great but here's the main
point it's one of my main points is that
I don't think human imitate III is the
right goal it should be to build really
large-scale systems that take in data
and make all kinds of decisions and all
kinds of scales maybe for people maybe
for naught but it's it's that kind of
system that we need and we're trying to
build and I do think about domains not
like vision or robotics but I think
about medical domains where you're
taking in all kinds of data all around
the world right this moment and
decisions were being made for people's
health right this moment and all those
things should be related so that if you
discover something good for Jeff and
Jeff similar to me that that should
immediately apply to me and if we start
to make errors we should control those
so we don't make too many errors and we
worry about provenance of how the data
and was collected in this particular
situation is it still relevant for this
situation all the kind things you think
about like in the banking industry about
how you move money around think about
doing that for things like medical
decisions so think of all the systems
issues there so that's not real AI but
it's really really important all right
so just this kind of phrase I like to
say to make an overall in system and to
behave intelligently it's neither a
necessary nor sufficient to make each
component of the system be intelligent
so if you've ever did statistical
physics or economics this is very
familiar to you but it's not ever or
it's not enough to express in our field
okay we want to we want to think about
systems that are really intelligent
because they maybe have market
principles here's another kind of
provocative point which is that if you
ask people what they're working on who
are doing the current in the current AI
wave they often will say oh intelligence
we're trying erst and intelligence again
I I personally don't think that's what
we're doing right now and if you work on
natural language semantics you're
starting to get there it's not that
no-one's working on it but what most
people aren't just taking it in data and
and and doing neural nets it's not
intelligence but the other thing they
often
autonomy all right I'm gonna build an
autonomous system because as if that's
so why well if I can build an autonomous
system I can sit back and you know say
wow look at that I did it it's
intelligent and its autonomous you know
it's a bragging point that I was able to
I don't have to guide it and if you're a
robot assist that's a reasonable goal
but for the rest of us I don't think it
is at all we want to build a system it
integrates well with the rest of us
right and it shouldn't be autonomous
even a self-driving car shouldn't be
autonomous it should be communicating at
all times of all the other cars around
it and if a tree fell down it should
tell all the other cars and it should be
highly networked and all the incentives
should be set up so that goes down the
right Street the right place the kiddin
depend on all the other traffic and so
on and so forth it should not be
autonomous it should be exactly the
opposite ok so I like to demote autonomy
as the goal I think was like a bragging
point that will rebuild autonomous
systems we should brag that we're
building highly interconnected systems
all right so here's my favorite slide
for this particular talk these are some
of the things I really work on and have
been working on for 10 or 20 years I
consider these challenges in the broader
enterprise of intelligent data oriented
decision-making systems I call this
let's call this AI if you look at those
most of those are not the classical AI
goals okay some of them are like you
know abstraction and explanation but a
lot of them are not so multiple
decisions I don't mean just a sequence I
mean like a hundred thousand or related
decisions in any given moment how do you
do that I'll talk a little bit at that
systems to create markets that don't
just create a so-called intelligence
dealing with uncertainty still to this
day things like neural nets taking an
input they produce an output and there's
no uncertainty associated with that
that's just dead wrong for the future if
you're gonna make medical decisions for
people and you make an output that says
you have to have a heart transplant I
want to know how I'm sure you that did
you look at this other data do you know
this thing about me let's have a
dialogue and that's part of the
explanation what if experiments all that
it's got to be surrounding these systems
so how do you do uncertainty well things
like jackknife and bootstrap you
resample you try out alternatives you
look at what if experiments that's how
you assess uncertainty and our current
systems I mean they're algorithms for
doing this but our current systems don't
do any of that okay mostly
they're you know they're Bayes nets that
kind of put in uncertainty with a prior
probability
you know there's not there's very little
frequentist uncertainty cloud edge
interactions if your systems people you
know the importance of that will have
different knowledge in different places
when we have cloud and edge interacting
at different time scales and you got to
be thinking about that how do you
coordinate all the different how to date
knowledge abstractions I just emphasize
that that's that if you were to ask me
why do you not think we have
intelligence right now
that's the main reason humans are
extremely good at thinking up and I'm
thinking through abstractions that's
what we do in computer science really
well but so we do in mathematics so even
science that's what children do
extremely well and that's what our
current systems are just incapable of
doing right I mean yes you have a little
bit of features and neural nets to do
vision and that's being called
abstraction but that's far from what
humans that's what a really intelligence
system can do is think up and reason
with abstractions so it's a research
problem doesn't mean it's do it we
shouldn't work you know that it's it's a
research problem it'll take a long time
so let me just dig into a couple of
these again I think all of these are
immense it's not that no one's working
on this not just my group but many
groups are but when you say AI machine
learning no one has all these in mind
they just have mini batch and you know
distributed training of neural nets and
all that that's what is nowadays and I
just I want people to spread their wings
to some of these other are really really
important challenges if you go into a
company like this one or you know and
Alibaba and China or whatever this is
the kind things they actually work on
most of them don't work on a big system
with you know and mini-batch training
and so on Soph alright let me just
mention multiple decisions in real
problems like transportation to take an
example you can't just have each entity
be autonomous and thinking about nobody
but at him or herself you have to make a
lot of Blink decisions these decisions
will often interact now if there's no
scarcity it they don't really interact
that much but as soon as you have
scarcity like in a real world economic
system then decisions will start to
interact you have to worry about that
okay so let's think about systems that
create markets now let me take just a
very very simple example to try to bring
this home recommendation systems to me
were one of the more powerful
achievements in machine learning
literature or machine learning history
okay before the current era you know
they took in lots of data and they help
people make decisions not just you find
features and so on they help people make
decisions what books am i interested in
and so on the way they worked solely
this day is that the none of the
decisions interact
so if I come in to the Amazon system
today they'll feature ëismí in some way
and they'll put me probably into a
neural net these days and they'll output
some recommendations there's some books
or some movies or something else Chris
comes in later they will feature ice
Chris and they will put him into the you
know the same neural net and they'll
make some recognition for him and those
are totally unrelated
right well so if you're recommending a
movie that's fine if they recommend the
same movie to me and to Chris and all of
the rest of you in the room or hundreds
of people that's no problem they just
drink the bits to everybody no problem
what if you recommend the same book to
everybody and well it's probably still
not a problem you can do what's called
print on demand but you know getting in
maybe a hundred thousand copies of a
book to all the people who order today
that's not it easy so it starts to
become a little just a little scarcity
there but now what if you recommend so
you're trying to make a really good
recommendations for things like
restaurant seats that you know I not
just added a bunch of advertisements but
actually really bids and you know link
you up to restaurants that you might
want be interested in it may be at 10%
discounts and so on well you can't
recommend the same restaurant seat to a
hundred thousand people all right and
you'll Creek ingestion so you have to
instead build a you have to load balance
and you have to do this really with a
market you don't know what people really
want what their preferences are you
don't what the restaurants really are
you know have available so you can't
just have the computer know all of this
so you have to build a market where the
restaurants can bid on the people and
people can accept or reject and start to
create you know a two-way a two-sided
market what if I reckon if I build a
really good app for doing how do you get
to the airport you know pathfinding
if just a small number of people are
using it no problem but if everybody is
using it it might recommend the same
path to everybody and I create
congestion and that's already how you
start to see that happening and with
some of the apps is sort of these when
they get big well you can't not just you
have to think about that we can't cut
creating congestion in our lives and
here's another example as my favorite
one is that you know like in China right
now everybody's got a little bit of
money and you know a thousand dollars
and they want to invest it for the first
time in their life now that you know
might buy a mutual fund or something
well if US then other apps exist which
helped people to make their investment
right well if that app suggests to a
hundred thousand people today to buy
Microsoft stock the stock is gonna go up
artificially and that's gonna move the
market and it's gonna destabilize the
market you cannot do that okay all right
so I hope you get the sense this is real
right and at the same time there's the
classical problem of multiple decisions
that's more statistical and these are
quite orthogonal but you have to solve
both of them and I hope you all kind of
know about how you make decisions now
under uncertainty not under scarcity if
you make decisions under uncertainty
what you do is that you need to make a
decision here do jelly beans cause acti
well you randomly put half of your
people in there do an a/b test half the
people go here with they eat jelly beans
half of people don't eat jelly beans and
then you ask say their skin condition
six months later and probably there'll
be no effect you know it'll be within
the error bars and you can get a p-value
a quantitative assessment that there's
no if there's no you you're making a
real decision based on some certainty in
this disco paradigm but yeah as you know
the people don't stop there they don't
just make one test they say well it's
just a particular color that causes it
so now they do the a/b test you know 100
times all right and now by chance alone
they put people just happen to have bad
skin the condition and the treatment
condition and they will look like they
have Bad's condition after the test and
it looks like oh I've made a discovery
green jelly beans cause acne right now
this is if you had any statistics you
know about this but you probably all
know the solutions to this okay and the
software I know of no software that
anybody is built in the machine on
ensure that that puts in false discovery
rate control which was the kind of one
of the ways to deal with this all right
so you can deal with this there's a
notion called false discovery rate and
it's not an error rate error rate is
just a single number all right it's a
it's it's a ratio there's a numerator
and a denominator and you want that
ratio to be small you can make it be
small by having the numerator small
that's a classical error rate going down
or the new denominator can be big okay
and so you can control the fraction of
bad decisions in your entire lifetime
not just on one day not just in one
decision or a whole group of people that
you can have that fraction be controlled
okay so this is something we've worked
on at Berkeley here's a very recent
paper there's an algorithm called dagger
and there is the algorithm you can put
that in your software that will control
false discovery rate in an online
setting across lots and lots of
decisions by making the numerator and
the denominator be controlled and it
doesn't require independence and so on
so forth so this is real you can do real
math with this kind of thing and it
should be done put that together with
the economic perspective and now there's
wonderful research challenges going
forward okay
right I haven't seen a sign telling me
how much time I have left so I'm a
little uncalibrated here how five
minutes okay it's a little bit more
about this markets business so you know
people talk a lot about AI killing jobs
and all that and there's certainly some
truth to that but there's people aren't
talking enough about ways you can create
jobs and I think that if you take a
markets perspective instead of a
classically hyper society you can start
to see this much more clearly all right
so consider the music situation so I
need those unclutter market more people
are now making music than ever before in
history because you know laptops allow
you to make really good music and some
people are really good at it on the
weekend they create great music they put
it on soundcloud all right and then they
lose control of it entirely so then
services like Spotify or Pandora will
stream it to large numbers people and
more people are listening in that stuff
than ever before in history never it's
not everyone listen to Beyonce they're
all listening this stuff but there's no
market there's no connection between the
producer and consumer and so economic
value is being lost probably billions of
dollars of economic value is being lost
right so how do you restore that well
you use machine learning and economics
together to create a market right how do
you do that well there's a company I
call the United masters some very famous
musicians are behind this and real tech
people and so they just they partner
with sites like this and they've they've
looked at the data flow and they said
well there was a data flow I can put a
price on that and make it trend any
economic transaction out of it so I can
create a dashboard for musicians so you
know if Chris is only on Chris again is
making music on the weekend he drives a
taxi during the week if he has the
dashboard he learns that in Austin Texas
you know of 10,000 people listened to
him last week I'm just he's popular
there for what everything he knows he
could go to Austin book a room and make
you know ten thousand dollars and if he
does that five times during the year
that's a salary so you'd have to drive
his taxi or be a professor during the
week he can actually now become a
musician and this starts to scale you
could think of now hundreds of thousands
or millions of people in various
countries actually starting to get a job
because they have access to the data
about their skill set and now I didn't
have to be just music it can be writing
it could be art it can be all kinda here
cutting and so on so forth all right so
let's liberate ourselves to think about
AI in this way that we create
connections where data flows and we
allow economic value to be created not
that we try to replace
intelligence with computers last little
point on my to last two minutes this is
a little advertisement is that when you
start thinking about multiple decisions
you do have to think about sequences
going forward not just simultaneous
which I've emphasized and this is the
area of optimal control theory it's now
often called reinforcement learning but
it's just optimal control theory and I
really want to hope the systems
community will start to resonate to the
need to build systems that allow you to
do optimal control and so now you have
to face the fact that lots of the tasks
that you need to run have very very
different lifetimes that you're going to
do a search process through a sequence
of control actions and sometimes you'll
learn very quickly that was a bad idea
another particular path through the tree
of actions looks like a very good idea
for a long long time so if you start
secrets processes up and you have them
all wait for each other you're gonna be
waiting way too long in many many
situations so the MapReduce paradigm is
not appropriate for lots of these kinds
of control tasks so let me just sort of
skip ahead here's just a kind of a
little picture to suggest this if you're
trying to make a simulated robot perform
then what you're gonna do is try all the
actions of all the joints and everything
and try to build a policy doing that you
do lots of what are called rollouts and
alphago did rollouts most of the
so-called success reinforcement all
based on these rollouts in a big big big
tree
alright so we have been working on this
system called ray there's some several
students and then john stoick and myself
at berkeley are leaving this and it is
all about trying to do parallel version
of python where you can have very
heterogeneous tasks some of them are
very short some are very long and
there's no synchrony anywhere it's all a
big data flow graph where the data the
graph itself is dynamic okay so I'd like
to think about this as in Python you've
got functions and you've got objects and
they're both really really useful when
people went to Map Reduce Jeff Dean and
others they kept functions but they
threw out objects that wasn't it was all
functional programming alright so we
want to restore objects because we think
they're really important so array is
basically does that so functions are now
called tasks that are distributed
functions and objects are now called
actors in the classical language of
actors so they are stateful so we built
a system that does this here's some
performance I guess here 16 nodes rate
to get up to a million tasks per second
so tasks of are lightweight and they can
be used for these rollouts
it is a working system I'll show you
github dress here a second much much
could work on scheduling local and
global scheduling and much much work on
making sure that objects are in the
right place at the right time here's a
little bit of code using this it's
basically Python with some annotators
that decorators that tell you that some
things are gonna be paralyzed and I'm
not gonna show you a little video of
this actually working but I could let me
just go back to them for the last slide
so there it is of the github address and
by the way I'm going to China a lot
these days and one of them my big
achievements in China is to get some of
the companies there to do open-source
development and so there's companies
doing open source development of ray for
the first time ever in history so I'm
hoping that that it'll partly take off
in China all right so to summarize my
message it's great era don't just focus
on neural nets there's all kinds of
other problems and build systems that
focus on all those other problems
because they will be the ones that are
actually start to get used in industry
and have an impact on the world and will
start to open up new research venues
it's gonna take decades to get this
field right this field is really not AI
this field is really a new engineering
discipline it's like my father who did
chemical engineering in the 40s that was
the thing to do in the forties you know
take the chemical principles and turn it
into systems factories and that's what
we're doing right now we're taking the
principles of decision making a data and
analysis and all that and together
computing and we're building systems
that make human life better and that's
gonna take decades and I think that's
the enterprise we're involved in so let
me just put that slide up again this
summarizes what I think of some of the
challenges but new ones are gonna be
emerging so thank you
[Applause]
Thank You professor Jordan so our next
speaker is Chris Rea chris is an
associate professor in the department of
computer science at Stanford and he's
also affiliated with the statistical
machine learning group pervasive
parallelism lab and the Stanford AI lab
Chris's research is unique it sits in at
this intersection of database theory
systems and machine learning work from
his group has been incorporated into
major scientific and humanitarian
efforts including IceCube neutrino
detector paleo deep Drive and mimics in
the fight against human trafficking into
commercial products he co-founded a
company that was acquired by Apple in
2017 and I guess Professor Jordans put
me on the spot and so I appreciate that
yes so what I'm gonna talk about today
is really pretty much in line with what
Mike was talking about earlier which is
this drive to take machine learning and
make it into an engineering discipline
and one of the catch words for this
that's going on right now is this
software 2.0 now the first time I said
software 2.0 I have to admit I kind of
threw up in my mouth a little bit
you know I've soaked up about as much
Silicon Valley as one human being can
soak up but even by my standards like
that seemed like a little bit out over
my skis but what I've started to realize
as I walked around to you know all the
different companies and folks that are
down there and an up here in Seattle is
that the way people are building
software is really changing and that's
to me gonna drive a lot of the change
for where machine learning research I
think can have the most impact and also
build the most interesting products to
impact the world so if you've seen these
software 2.0 things the term was coined
by Andrey Carpathia in a blog post but
when you think about that you probably
think about these really fancy
applications like translation robotics
all kinds of imaging and you probably
think about neural nets and you wouldn't
be too wrong one of the things that
kicked us off is this you know Google
system that shrink their language
translation system from you know five
hundred thousand lines of kind of
conventional C++ code down to five
hundred lines or so of kind of you know
commodity machine learning
and that seemed five hundred lines of
code more or less actually you know
Facebook could replicate and Microsoft
can replicate and a graduate student in
Germany could replicate and something
pretty exciting that these days Mike was
calling them end-to-end applications are
becoming these insane commodities so
quickly is really exciting and it
changes where you're gonna put the you
know high value PhD people actually
doing any work but it's been really
exciting as it's not just those you know
end to end you know
AI first mem L first applications
there's a bunch of stuff that's going on
that's really exciting that's taking
these principles and applying them all
over the place I'll talk a little bit
about hollow clean that yeah Billy uh
Cynthia are doing I'm taking these ideas
and applying them to problems like data
cleaning in and the extract transform
load process and data integration
Andy Pavel is doing a bunch of really
cool work on tuning databases and tuning
systems using machine learning and
there's also cool work going on and and
networks as well and so this this
transition where machine learning sort
of works well enough that it becomes a
building block for these systems means
we kind of have to think through like
how is software engineering going to
change and that's why I think this
software 2.0 is kind of an interesting
paradigm so what does it look like well
you know it's a vague buzzword so let me
try and put a little bit of you know
meat around it so kind of conventionally
software 1.0 you write code C++ Python
code and you compile down to an ISA
right you know machine based instruction
may be kind of CUDA kind of compiling
what's going on in software 2.0 is two
big changes at the top and at the bottom
at the top what's changing is the
abstraction right what how you actually
build these applications and what you do
is you feed them training data by and
large so that's the that's the input
that you're giving to these systems
underneath what's really exciting to me
the first time in computing since I've
been around in it is that instead of
compiling down to instructions you're
compiling down to like a blast like data
flow like call and so the hardware has a
chance to reach up and actually change
as well so both the top and the bottom
of software changing that seems pretty
exciting and interesting ok so why is
this happening now conventionally people
focus a lot on quality they say oh I
built a system that has you know higher
than human accuracy at text X Y or Z
under some very very simple you know
reasoning but what's exciting is that
actually this is a way to build a lot of
products with high quality faster you
have people who don't have machine
learning PhDs who maybe have you know
sort of basics of statistics being able
to build and deploy high quality
products in a small amount of time and
the speed to develop them is amazing
also the maintainability rather than
having hand-tuned crazy feature I
systems they're building these systems
that are basically getting all those
low-level details right for them so they
can focus on building products so that
speed of execution is just dramatically
different what's also exciting is that
the deployment story has changed so
neural nets have kind of become weirdly
enough like a new JVM and what I mean by
that is that they're the language that
you compile down when you want to ship
code so the hyper scalars you know
Microsoft very famously has a bunch of
great stuff like brainwave you can
compile down to hardware for neural nets
and once you do a bunch of problems are
almost solved for you in particular
qualification this process you go
through at any of the hyper scalars
where you have code you want to ship it
to the data center it gets much much
easier if you've compiled down to our
neural net there's no allocation on the
critical path it's using a set of
operators that people have pre-qualified
it's changing in that incentive changes
what engineers want to build because
they can get their software out there so
much faster now in a parallel life with
Kuhn lay the father of multi-core and a
guy named Rodrigo Liang who led a
thousand person chip group at Oracle we
are actually you know some of our
research is being commercialized to
actually build hardware for ML which is
really exciting and there are all kinds
of underneath changes about how sort of
today's neural nets are trained that are
allowing sort of hardware to really
really radically change and come up and
meet this abstraction that's not what
I'm going to talk about I'm gonna focus
more on that level of abstraction about
how programming and building these
things is really exciting so the way we
got into this was about two years ago we
kind of looked at this landscape of
every week if you remember in sort of
2016 you would wake up and look at
archive and something else would be
posted this neuron that does that this
neural net does that was kind of a mad
dash for innovation and we looked at
that and we said well this you know a
lot of people are working on that
problem we want to work on something
else and we kind of bet that that was
going to become a commodity and so what
we thought was gonna happen we didn't
know the term software 2.0 but we kind
of thought that deep learning would
basically Plateau and hit a commodity
point where people could download and
build software with it pretty reliably
and so we publish this paper in mid-2016
that we call data programming that
started to think about what was
happening up the stack and I'll tell you
about the software that we've been
building to implement this idea over the
last couple of years now the key
observation was that if you look at
where engineers were spending their time
they weren't spending their time
building new models they weren't
spending their time actually tweaking
the underlying systems they actually
weren't even worried that much about run
time they just put it on some GPUs maybe
they go get a coffee
where they were spending all their time
was basically creating and feeding
training data to these systems and we
thought because we have sort of a
theoretical bent why isn't there any
mathematical structure around sort of
creating training data
why does sort of machine learning
conventionally start with data coming
from God herself and showing up in XY
pairs even though all those XY pairs
were generated by a huge system that's
consuming all of people's time and so
what we decided to do was try and build
both mathematical and systems models of
what was going on there with the hope of
both better understanding it and also
hopefully accelerating that process and
that's where this thing snorkel was born
okay now very quickly we stumbled on one
little technical nugget but there are
many things in this space and I'll try
and highlight that was this key idea
that if you're going to program software
2.0 by getting training data then maybe
what was holding you back in some
situations was leveraging all the
sources that were available to you of
various different quality and so what we
started to do or develop program
abstractions really simple program
abstractions that could just talk about
different sources that were informing
your training data and the mathematical
questions were to be able to learn the
accuracy of those sources and the
correlations among those sources but
without any conventional training data
okay now when we started this people
were kind of skeptical saying like well
we'll build bigger neural nets and you
know that will be the way to higher
quality on state-of-the-art tasks and we
didn't care we said well we were gonna
go after people who you know we're just
deploying these things inside companies
you know who are medical people and all
the rest who just needed to build these
products but what's been interesting is
over the last year the state of the art
for things like image net even a kind of
straight-ahead benchmark have both come
out of tools that basically allowed you
to do more weak supervision on top
facebook published this thing about
using
tags in various different ways the auto
augment people did something really cool
that followed up on some stuff that we
were up to about learning data
augmentations and learning composition
and the point is is that these other
signals to build real products always
exist when you go to build a real
product but the benchmarks don't capture
them and so this kind of engineering
challenge of bringing in more and more
signal seems to actually be catching on
even for the benchmarks another thing
that we'll highlight here he hubs in the
audience you should definitely talk to
him he's the real expert here but or
even on things like conventional things
like data cleaning being able to apply
these ideas of weak supervision and
automatic future generation gives you
tremendous benefit in terms of precision
and recall compared to the state of the
art and ahaab is definitely expert he's
back over there you should you should
talk to him about hollow clean and have
a big website and and theo is working on
this as well so the point is like this
stuff is coming but we don't really have
any engineering abstractions for it and
that's what I'd like to build okay so we
started building snorkel led by two
great folks one Stephen Bach and another
great student Alex Ratner he's on the
market this year you'll see his picture
many times right there's this picture so
Stephen Bach who's now doing some stuff
at Google related to this and Alex
Ratner really led this project as well
he's on the market please hire him okay
now what do I want you to show you first
thing is programming is changing so not
only can we descale many tasks that was
our original goal make it easier for
more people to use machine learning we
also realized very quickly in our
conversations with folks in industry
that even the experts the seven-figure
salary folks coming out of grad school
they were having similar kinds of
problems and that even experts were
building and stumbling on these problems
of training data generation and data
augmentation so we wanted to study those
the second thing is if you look at
classical questions around supervised
machine learning once you start to
realize that you don't have you know
labeled data that you can trust many
different things actually change
underneath the covers about how you
estimate source accuracy and
correlations and all the rest there's a
bunch of really classical theoretical
work that goes underneath the covers
that were really excited about and the
point is also there's a lot more to do
all kinds of things in the pipeline data
augmentation ETL can be modeled and
potentially make it easier to build
applications and I don't claim that we
have solutions that are even very good
but they're our first cut on these
and there's a lot more to do to be able
to build these end-to-end machine
learning kinds of products okay so as I
mentioned this is mainly a trolling
slide you know data was the new oil so
training data is the new new oil I have
no real idea why but it's a really a
fundamental problem in machine learning
that you need high quality training data
as Mike talked about most of the
applications of deep learning are almost
all of them really come through a lot of
supervised data okay and as I mentioned
traditional view is that this data just
kind of falls out of the sky and you're
giving it but every application that
really generates dollars that I'm aware
of that training data was created by a
process people software all kinds of
things go into that process and the key
idea that I want to show you is that by
modeling that process that provenance
you know Mike use the the same turn as
well modeling the provenance of that
process actually can improve the quality
and that's kind of the art project of it
is it possible that going and
understanding that pipeline and
mathematically modeling it does anything
for the downstream tasks and actually
the answer is yes and that's what we've
been working on for the last couple of
years in this project okay so that's
what snorkel is it's all online we've
been running workshops about it because
you'll see they're a bunch of users for
it which is exciting and we're modeling
this training set creation process and
data augmentation process and there's a
blog and all the rest of that crap
alright so how does it work I won't go
into too much technical detail because
we have really short talks but please
ask me please check out the blog and
send feedback the first and simplest
abstraction that we could we could use
was this idea of just functions so the
idea was that what you're gonna have is
a bunch of maps that took your training
fit in and then mapped to every point
you can imagine it's binary
classification just to make the
discussion simpler yes no or I don't
know I don't know it's critically
important by the way that's where a lot
of the interesting intellectual work
happens and you would provide these
functions and they would generate noisy
labels you don't know the accuracy you
don't know the correlations of the
labels and you but you know that they're
not probably not of perfect quality then
the second piece is that you would model
those labeling functions outputs and we
chose to model them as graphical models
basically for historical reasons and
because we could prove theorems about
them and you would try and figure out in
those graphical models what are the
parameters of those models how accurate
is every source how correlated is it
with those different pieces but
the twist is instead of seeing a bunch
of observations we would only see where
they agreed and disagreed and we would
try to come up with basically
statistical models that would allow us
to conclude we could learn those
parameters provably and that's what way
basically the program that we've been on
for the last couple of years where you
don't actually get to see the value why
and then finally to take advantage of
all this nice deep learning stuff we
would then label the entire training set
with accuracy so instead of getting a 0
1 or minus 1 you get a probability
distribution and we would pass that to a
deep model and we would hope that that
uncertainty quantification would allow
it to do a better job it would know to
trust some points more than other points
ok now I don't have slides here but you
can definitely look on the website about
this this actually surprisingly has big
impacts on things like natural language
processing applications cross-modal
applications all kinds of different
places where we've demonstrated this on
NLP and vision and images this
quantification of uncertainty actually
seems to help in some cases that it
helps ever is great we're really excited
about that and it never seems to hurt
and that's really the kind of theory
that we've been trying to work out more
importantly it changes how people
program and so we've been basically
giving demos to people and allowing them
to write code on it and a bunch of folks
at industry and companies won't put some
logos up later or actually using this to
build applications and so what we're
after here is trying to understand how
this changes the programming model and
again we're at the early days here we
don't we don't exactly claim that we
have the right thing but there's a lot
that can change when you start to view
sort of your way of programming and as
generating training data ok so let me
give you one example of something that
changes kind of concretely it's actually
a real person who was building one of
the early versions of the system using a
technique called distant supervision
okay so what they were doing is they
first wrote a bunch of these in our
terminology labeling functions and they
were very highly accurate very precise
they labeled to say 10000 points at 90%
accuracy ok then they came along and
said you know I don't have enough
coverage in my model what I need to do
is label a bunch more points and they
wrote a lower quality labeling function
that labeled that say a million points
at 60 percent accuracy
okay now conventionally what you would
do is basically assume that all those
labels came from a uniform source and as
a result what you would have without
modeling that lineage or Providence was
a set of data
that looked like it was about sixty
point three percent accurate you
wouldn't remember if you liked that you
had that high accuracy pool and
unfortunately that will make your
overall model quality go down which is
extremely bad and frustrating as a user
of this programming model because you
gave the system more information and
then your quality to the eye looks much
much worse very very frustrating but of
course as I've told you kind of the fix
is obvious if you remember where these
came from even if I didn't tell you the
accuracy you have a better job of
estimating which training points you
should trust which were high precision
which are low precision the art is to
figure out automatically what those
accuracies are without seeing training
data so it's a very frustrating
experience for user but it's the kinds
of things that we've been basically
publishing papers about and so without
going into too much technical detail
here basically we can probably learn the
accuracy of these labeling functions
even among correlations among them
without hand labelled data and even
features under which they work we can
actually surface Feker features of them
and this is a sort of long we're not at
the end of this we continually keep
publishing essentially improvements to
when we can learn and can we match
supervised scaling rates in many cases
we can match supervised scaling rates in
some places we can estimate correlations
we may actually improve some old
supervised bounds of learning graphical
model structure with this over the
summer which is really exciting so this
is the goal change the programming model
and figure out what we can offload and
make automatic and understand the
minimal statistical assumptions that
allow us to do basically carry out this
program and that's what we've been after
one thing that was just posted it's been
in use with a bunch of our collaborators
is doing multi task supervision stuff
and multi task learning it turns out
real applications don't have just one
kind of classified output by learning
across multiple tasks you can do a much
better and more robust job of dealing
with care this is something that we've
put out and actually you know Mike
mentioned Alibaba
these guys are amazing if you're not
paying attention to Alibaba compared to
a US company they're amazingly open they
took our software when it was like as
alpha as possible used it showed us
where it was used in their pipeline gave
us a bunch of feedback and actually in
part some of the reason we we prioritize
doing the MTL stuff was because of that
amazing technical feedback they gave us
okay so this is something called metal
just released and the theory has gotten
dramatically cleaned up it's a little
bit more fancy than it was before but
mathematically it's much nicer and it's
practically quite useful because you can
build these tasks at multiple different
levels of abstraction you can do parsing
natural sort of you know tagging for
types you can do question understanding
all in one model and sort of where one
model is weak another one could be
strong and you can actually characterize
this and why it improves generalization
a lot of that was done you know 10-15
years ago when people were looking at
how multitask learning was was you know
actually beneficial but in this new
regime where you don't trust your
training data there are a couple of
twists and turns there but it's a great
software abstraction okay as I mentioned
this software is only about two years
old but here are some of the users and
sponsors and there are actually many
users who are not on the slides we run
these workshops and people kind of are
able to build something with it again
this is not great software this is
graduate students stuff but people are
able to pick it up and actually use it
because it fulfills this niche that
there's no programming abstraction so
our bar is pretty low because there's
nothing else that's allowing you to kind
of think about that training set
generation process and I hope some folks
get excited in the audience and build
something much better than than what we
have I was asked to give a hot take in
my last two minutes and I would so I
will so one of the things you know Mike
was talking about you know the
difference between AI and machine
learning I think sometimes even learning
itself is not what people actually want
an industry or it's overused in a way
that maybe leads them astray and there's
nothing wrong with learning it's
fantastic you know the the
generalization results and all the rest
are great but they're sometimes
misapplied or misunderstood by engineers
and it leads them into a kind of a
morass so as I mentioned ml's big impact
to me has been how it changes software
engineering and deployment it's
introduced this new JVM like layer and
it's allowed people to program far more
easily than they could before but a lot
of what engineers really want is just
not to have too tediously specify every
line of their program they really want
something that looks a lot more like
interpolation and so we actually started
thinking about this a while back about
well what would an interpolation system
look like
now conventionally if you talk to an ml
person which is not formally true for
any reason the inequality goes the wrong
direction to make this statement
they think that interpolation implies
that you're not learning because
interpolation means you're memorizing
the training set you're getting zero
loss but these two things are not
actually in opposition you can actually
get robust interpolation you can get
everything right you can do what you're
told and still learn and generalize to
the rest of the data set and this is a
pretty interesting thing because
traditionally when I watch engineer
struggle they'll say things like the
model is overfitting but they'll have no
idea that what they're talking about is
the error that's on their test set to
their validation set there's nothing to
do with overfitting but they sort of
adopt this ethos that learning basically
means you have to make mistakes and
that's not true on a lot of the products
if a hundred people asked a question
every day every assistant in the world
should get it right that doesn't
actually happen okay so I think reliable
interpolation is one way to think about
sort of a next generation for learning
and statistical ideas can really play
well now when I was thinking about this
I thought it myself it was kind of
heresy but then I went to ISMP which is
this great conference it's mathematical
programming conference and I was lucky
enough that Misha was speaking after me
and he's and as a result I was reading
some of his papers
Misha's at Ohio State you should check
out his work he had this really cool
stuff which is a little bit insider
baseball but it's pretty interesting
which is about how kernels the kernel
methods can actually interpolate a
family-like interpolate people knew that
part but could also get minimax optimal
rates so sort of like the best race you
could hope for for these kind of
nonparametric estimators you know in the
corresponding holder class this is
really fascinating because it means that
they're not in opposition so we have a
chance of building dramatically more
reliable systems than we were building
before potentially right so that's an
interesting way to think about it and
also those minimax rates are all up to
label noise and so as I was talking
about before kind of the role of why
we're modeling label noise in our
construction process you could
potentially get better rates by modeling
that noise and that's a program that
we're we're carrying out right now if
you haven't run Missha stuff it's
amazing like his work is really like
it's you know one of those fun times of
being in academia where you read someone
else's papers and send them like frantic
happy emails about you know how exciting
it was and I got the chance to go hang
out with him in Bordeaux so definitely
check his stuff out I think it's super
cool so that's the end of my talk you
know as at the end of the reality
distortion bubble I don't know but what
I wanted to get across to you if you
don't know who the dog is you haven't
been read
enough reddit anyway but what I wanted
to get across to you is that I think
programming is really fundamentally
changing its changing from below in
terms of how we actually build our
applications and this opportunity for
hardware to race up and meet this new
abstraction we're there a huge number of
high dollar workloads that are going
into a fairly narrow but still kind of
general pipeline that's really exciting
I talked a little bit just as proof of
concept that hey there's more stuff we
can model and sort of the process that
generates the data for machine learning
that's all snorkel is really about in
the auto augment stuff all that stuff is
really about what goes into the top can
we model more of that instead of having
it as a black box
what are those models look like we
showed a first cut but there's a lot
more to do
thanks so much for your time and
attention I mention that I'm sure all of
us have a bunch of questions we're just
going to you know do a Q&A session in
the end with all the four speakers up
here so yeah please hold on to your
questions so our next speaker is Vivian
C Weavin is a associate professor at MIT
in the electrical engineering and
computer science department she's really
one of the world's leading experts in
energy of air signal processing
algorithms and more recently has been
looking at Asics for DNS and machine
learning algorithms right prior to
joining MIT she was a member of
technical staff in R&D Center at Texas
Instruments where she was a part of the
GCT video coding committee in defining
the high efficiency video coding
standard and for this she received the
Primetime Emmy engineering word so she's
raising the bar she's raising the bar
really high for these awards Emmys and
Oscars and you know Oscar next thank you
very much for the introduction so the
focus of my talk will be a little bit
different primarily we're going to focus
on how do we enable energy-efficient
computing at the edge for both deep
learnings and beyond that and this work
is in collaboration with a lot of my
students as well as other collaborators
at MIT so I'm gonna try and cover three
key messages in my talk so first I'm
gonna talk about the limitations of
existing efficient DNN design approaches
then we're going to talk about looking
beyond you know critical about DNA and
accelerators but can we get acceleration
by looking beyond the accelerator itself
and then looking at other opportunities
of doing inference at the edge beyond en
ends in general so very briefly what are
the limitations of existing DNN
approaches so we know that you know over
the past couple years there's been a
huge amount of effort to enable energy
efficient processing of deep neural nets
primarily because it's very desirable on
the edge devices and so within my team
we've been spending a lot of time
building tutorial material and surveys
about this topic and through this
process we actually found there were
several limitations and the existing
approaches that I want to highlight for
the research community so the first
thing is that because there's been a
huge amount of effort both on the
algorithm the hardware side particularly
an algorithm side we've seen things like
Network pruning will you make the
network sparse a lot of different new
network architectures to make it more
compact and also reduce precision in
this particular you know set of work
primarily the focus has always been on
reducing the number of Max or multiplies
and accumulate so computation as well as
weights but one question that we really
have when we're looking at the edge is
does this translate into energy savings
because that's what really directly
matters and we do know that we look at
the computer architecture itself or the
like where the energy actually goes and
mostly goes into data movement primarily
through the memory hierarchy and so
really what matters is kind of the order
by which the weight or the data that
goes to the neural network passes
through this memory hierarchy and the
data flow of the overall movement and so
in some sense you can say that the
weights and the operations are not all
in are all equal it really matters how
they move through the system to model
this some of the recent research within
my group has been to build up a modeling
methodology to model data movements so
for example here this is a model that's
based on our iris accelerator where you
can take in various DNN shapes as well
as the sparsity of the inputs and the
weights and you can get a breakdown in
terms of where the energy is actually
going from layer to layer and where in
the actual system and so using
information like this one thing that we
first want to figure out where is the
actually energy going and what is first
thing I want to really highlight is that
the number of weights alone is not
necessarily a good metric of the energy
itself there's many different types of
data movements that go on within the
system itself many different data types
so for example if we look at Google
Annette we know that weights account for
maybe 22 percent of the energy from data
movement but we can see that also
feature maps both input and output also
affect or significantly affect the
energy of the system as well through
data movement so we really shouldn't
just be focusing on the number of
weights in terms of trying to estimate
the energy cost and so one of the thing
that I really want to emphasize or push
is that the idea is that we really what
we want to do is rather than taking
weights or a number of operations as a
metric that we want to reduce so they're
really easy to calculate by looking at
the neural network itself if we will
eCare about energy or latency we should
directly target those particular metrics
during the design of the neural network
itself and so we can show for example
one example of this is the energyaware
pruning approach and the idea here is
that if we sort the layers based on the
energy consumption and let's say we
start pruning the layers that consume
the most energy first we know that as
you prune more accuracy tends to go down
so you basically want to spend you know
get the best bang for your buck spend
the money while spend the pruning where
it matters the most and if you do that
as opposed to just removing weights that
tend to be small you actually get better
energy savings so compared to a typical
magnitude based pruning approach which
is actually quite effective you can do
even better with energy aware pruning by
really removing the weights where they
actually matter so we can see here for
example on Alec's net about a 1.7 X
reduction in energy by driving really
the algorithm design based with the
energy metrics as opposed to just
looking at number of weights one
challenge of course is that what if you
don't actually have an energy model
available for you can you automate this
whole process by actually taking direct
metrics from an actual platform itself
so this is some work that we've done
recently with Google's mobile vision
team and the idea here for Net adapt is
that rather than again using an energy
mall to estimate the energy or the
latency we can take direct measurements
from a mobile platform itself and this
will incorporate things like the the
effects of the tool chain and if you
have some proprietary hardware where you
don't actually have the low-level
details of you can still take that
information those metrics that you care
about and insert it into the net adapt
algorithm and
we adapt the algorithm to really
minimize either latency or energy or a
combination of both and these are much
more directed towards the the metrics
that you actually care about when
optimizing the system as opposed to
again just counting the weights or
accounting number of ops and to just
showcase you know the impact of this if
you look at the the trade-off in terms
of let's say here accuracy versus
latency so the top left is better you
can see this is net adapt applied to
mobile net and this is actually the
smallest version of a very small version
of mobile net which is more difficult to
prune we you can see is that you can get
up to about 1.7 X reduction in latency
for the same around the same accuracy
and this is really because you're
driving the algorithm based on latency
as opposed to based on reducing the
number of operations so again the
message here is really can you
incorporate the direct metrics that you
care about latency energy or whatever
your system metrics are directly into
the optimization of the DNN itself as
opposed to other metrics like compute or
number of weights another thing I just
want to highlight more looking at the
hardware side is that now that we have
many of these energy-efficient DNN
design approaches from the algorithmic
perspective the one challenge from the
hardware perspective and when you build
accelerators is that there's no
guarantee as to which DNN approach or
algorithm an algorithm designer will
actually use and try and launch onto
your hardware so what's really important
also is to be able to develop hardware
that's flexible enough to exploit these
different features of these DNN
algorithms and so one of the challenges
that we see from doing this is
particularly in the design of
specialized enn hardware and they often
rely on certain properties of the DNN to
achieve the high energy efficiency so a
very typical specialized enn hardware
will use an array of multiplies and
accumulates and one benefit of doing
that is that you can reduce the memory
access by amortize the reads across the
mac array so for example in this
particular depiction I'm going to read
the weights I can reuse them across
multiple columns of the Mac array when I
read an activation I can use it across
multiple rows of the array so there's a
lot of reuse here and as as we mentioned
before memory access is very expensive
so the more you can reuse the more you
can reduce the energy cost and make the
system more energy efficient
however as we mentioned you know a lot
of these network architectures are
continuing to evolve and change and so
usually but the challenge with these
particular types of architectures that
we saw before was that the reuse in the
array utilization really depends on
specific properties of the DNN so for
example the number of channels the
feature map or batch size and so as a
results when you're relying when you
build hardware that really relies on
certain properties of the DNN but then
the the DN ends are varying in terms of
their architecture it's not going to be
enable your DN ends to be or your
accelerators to be efficient across a
wide range of compact Arkadia and
architectures the other thing to also
consider is that we often want to scale
up the size of these arrays for your
accelerators and so it's going to become
less efficient if you pin the the
utilization on certain dimensions of the
DNN and then you scale up the array size
the likelihood is the utilization of
your array is going to reduce as well
and so another thing is of course
mentioned that pruning and sparsity is
an also effective method of potentially
reducing the cost of processing these DN
ends but this can be challenging if
you're gonna use this kind of pinned
array structure so one of the focuses of
our next-generation iris is really
trying to balance this flexibility and
efficiency what we want is to be able to
support a wide range of filter States
shapes both large and compact many
different types of layers both
convolutional layers and fully connected
layers but also things that you start
thinking like mobile net depth-wise
layers are also important to support and
that often tends to be challenging
because the number of channels is
significantly reduced
you want to be able to support a wide
range of sparsity both dense and sparse
since you often don't have control as
the hardware designers to the degree of
sparsity of the neural network that's
going to be deployed on your device and
then you also want your architecture to
be scalable so for example if I scale up
the number of processing elements I also
want to see that my throughput also
scales up and that my energy efficiency
is also getting better and so what's
really important is that you're able to
find like if you have a very small
compact neural network you have the
flexibility to find where or what
dimension you can you reuse as much data
as possible and so by having a more
flexible data flow and knock and which
we'll talk about next
rc2 you're able to get over an
order-of-magnitude savings in terms of
both speed as well as energy efficiency
compared to v1 just to give you an idea
in terms of how we're getting this
flexibility in IRS v2 primarily the main
focus is to have a much more flexible
data flow and the particular way extend
rows stationery data flow into row
stationery Plus and what this really
means that enables you to do more
spatial mapping in all dimensions of the
PA array so that you can exploit more
data reuse in the multiple different
layer shapes so for example previously
if you're looking at let's say a depth
wise layer you really have you know very
limited in terms of number of channels
you have but if you can actually also
with row stationery plus not only fill
up your array based on filter width but
also channel groups and you can really
utilize your array much more fully and
then have higher throughput and have
higher efficiency to go along with the
more flexible data flow what you also
need is a more flexible knock or I know
C to actually support all these
different configurations in particular
you want to be able to have a knock that
you can deliver a multicast when you're
going to exploit high data reuse so for
example if you have a very large network
like Alex net where there's a lot of
reuse opportunity you want to have a
knock that can find that reuse and make
good use of it but at the same time you
also want this not to be flexible in the
case where you have layers that don't
have as much reused so for example the
fully connected layers or the depth-wise
layers and the compact networks and then
in that case you want your NOC to be
able to do unique s and deliver high
bandwidth just the same the throughput
and then of course as I mentioned
there's no real control in terms of the
degree of sparsity that you have so you
also want to make sure that your
hardware's or your NOC is flexible
enough to support both sparse and dense
layers and both though weights and
activations for the various different
configurations rather it be
convolutional layers or the fully
connected layers so that's basically
what you can do from the DNA and
accelerator point of view so really
again the message is to have more
flexibility from your hardware and truly
drive the design of your neural net
algorithms using real metrics such as
latency and energy the one thing though
is like sometimes there's certain limit
in terms of how fast you can actually
make your accelerator so one thing to do
is also look beyond the accelerator
itself and find other opportunities to
accelerate your processing and so I'll
give one example of why it's important
to look
on the DNA mech celery or what
opportunities there are particularly in
the space of super resolution right so
one important kind of application that
super resolution serves for mobile
devices is again taking low resolution
images and making it to high resolution
image this can be very useful if you
want to transmit low resolution image
because you have very limited bandwidth
or because just the size of their
screens continue to grow so it's very
useful for the viewing experience
however on a mobile device of course
again you have very limited compute and
we know that you know these days to say
- they are super resolution albums often
our CNN based and in fact if you to run
them on very high resolution images for
example from HD to Ultra HD the degree
of compute for these super resolution
algorithms are going to be exceptionally
high and they don't map well very much
to these mobile platforms so the one
that way that we try to address this is
to develop a framework that we can use
to accelerate the super resolution we
call it fast and the main idea is that
you are basically insert different super
resolution algorithms into this
framework we also take in the compressed
video and then you find opportunities to
accelerate it primarily by exploiting an
interesting property of the compressed
video itself so typically if you look
from a super resolution point of view at
you know a video what you actually view
it as is a you know a bunch of stacked
pixels however for us a person who
previously worked in computer video
video coding the way that I could pick a
look at compressed videos is in terms of
a more description of the block
structure or the structures of the
pixels within the videos itself so the
one way where we get really effectively
compressed video is to describe the
video figure out the correlations
between the pixels within a video itself
right so in fact the compressed video
itself is not just a set of pixels but a
lot of information about how different
pixels in the video is actually
correlated and so the goal here is that
can we use this compressed
representation to help accelerate super
resolution itself so in fact you can so
what you can do is rather than having a
bunch of low res videos and we applying
super resolution to every single frame
of the real resolution video what you
can actually do is you can apply super
resolution on only one of the frames and
then use this
correlation information for example
motion vectors to actually transfer the
information from one frame to one of the
high-resolution frames to all the other
high resolution frames and you can
generate basically all the other high
resolution frames without having to run
super resolution on every single one so
as a result super resolution is only
operating on a subset of these
particular frames this tends to be much
more computationally efficient because
this transfer is very cheap it only
involves basically some bicubic
interpolation and again it involves
using free information that you already
have in the compressed video itself so
if you transfer when n frames you just
basically get an NX acceleration
um so we verified this particular
approach on Y data set primarily the HVC
development data set of twenty different
videos I'm we're able to show that if
you transfer up to four frames there's
actually no loss in terms of quality and
if you transfer up to 16 frames there's
about 2.2 DB drop drop in psnr which is
not too bad at all
typically for these particular types of
applications it's really important to
actually look at the visual quality
itself so shown here in the video are
you know three different renditions of
the super resolution so on the left-hand
side you have the original SR CNN
algorithm with the highest quality on
the right hand side you have the bicubic
interpolation and you can see by looking
at the text of the cards that it's much
more fuzzier than the SR CN n however
then you have fast in the middle which
has the same complexity as the bicubic
algorithm on the right hand side but you
can see that the quality of fast
compared to the left hand side is also
very comparative competitive so the main
idea here is that you know while we can
do a lot of things to really accelerate
and make the DNA and accelerator more
efficient there are other properties
that we can look at beyond the
accelerator itself to improve the
processing or make the processing more
efficient in this particular case
looking at much more efficient
representations of the incoming data
that's actually there for free so one
final thing is looking beyond deep
neural networks itself what are some
opportunities in terms of weather types
of processing that we care about at the
particular edge so one of the projects
that we've been working on within my
group this is in collaboration with
Suresh chairman
Lucca car loan and the arrow astra
department is how to build very
low-power processing engines for
autonomous drone navigation particularly
nano drones we're talking about drones
the size of bottle caps or the size of a
quarter so in this particular project we
built a chip we call Navi on that
primarily does localization and mapping
at under around 30 milliwatts and the
real challenge is really fully
integrating all of that processing on
ship because when you're talking about
such a small drone you can't to have so
many external parts or it's no
components in terms of how this is what
this drone actually does it actually is
performing visual inertial odometry it's
basically taking in an image sequence as
well as I am.you measurements from
inertial accelerometer plus gyroscopes
and is taking these two particular
inputs in and then trying to determine
one the location of the drone itself so
shown on the upper right-hand corner you
can see that based on the visual data as
well as some i'm--you data is trying to
determine itself in the 3d world as well
as mapping the environment itself so
that's one of the key goals for this
particular type of processing and really
an important aspect of this particular
processing is to take in as I mentioned
the vision input as well as the IMU
input and you want to do some kind of
optimization of the vision data as well
as the estimate imitation of the IMU
data and typically this optimization is
done in the form of a factor graph to
help you infer the location of the drone
itself based on this incoming
information and basically this involves
solving a non linear least square factor
graph optimization you have factors that
are dictated based on the feature tracks
that you see from your vision side as
well as any IMU measurements that are
coming in and basically this is a large
graph you're talking about over 4,000
factors all the way you're trying to put
this on under a small drone and based on
these optimizations you can kind of
update what the states are and figure
out what the 3d map is and so similar
very similar to the deep learning space
you can also find opportunities to
exploit things like sparsity to reduce
the computation in particular here we
look at the fact that can exploit
sparsity you get a you know 5x reduction
in memory which is very important to the
area cost of these particular devices
and about a 7x increase in terms of
speed so what I want to show here is
just the other
2news other than DNS itself where
acceleration and the co.design of both
the algorithm and the hardware can
really enable increased energy
efficiency so to summarize we talked
about various different design
considerations for deep learning at the
edge the important thing is to make sure
you incorporate direct metrics such as
latency or energy into the design of the
algorithm itself to improve efficiency
and it's also really important given the
large number of efficient DNA and
algorithm techniques out there too so
pop hardware that can really support
flexible data flows and Knox to exploit
both the data reuse for energy
efficiency as well as to ensure that
your array is fully utilized for speed
it's also important to look beyond the
deep learning acceleration engine itself
for other opportunities to accelerate
your algorithms in particular you can
look at the representation that of the
data that's actually coming in in this
case recipie resolution we showed that
that was quite effective and then
finally there are other forms of
inference they can actually use to
actually you process at the edge beyond
deep learning so we showed one example
of using graphical models for
localization and mapping for nano drones
that concludes my talk thanks thanks
Vivian
so our final speaker for the session is
Jeff garden
Jeff is the research director for the
Microsoft Research Montreal lab and also
a professor of machine learning at
Carnegie Mellon University and Jeff is
very well known for you know his work on
AI systems that capture long-term
thinking such as reasoning long-term
reasoning reasoning to solve reasoning I
had to solve problems planning a
sequence of actions and inferring unseen
properties from observations he also has
a very unique perspective now as the
head of Microsoft's latest yeah I'll
have in Montreal all right thank you
very much so yeah so I thought the title
of the session was was chosen very
provocatively so I did my my best to
respond to it
so free inference and instant training
I'm not going to be
able to achieve either of those but I
wanted to want to talk a little bit
about how to make how to make these
things faster without sacrificing
quality so it was projecting a second
ago all right cool thank you all right
so um so right so I'm gonna take as
given that the right answer that we know
a right answer for inference and that
it's basically Bayes rule is implemented
in in graphical models but this answer
is incredibly expensive and there are a
lot of people who have done a lot of
great research on making it less
painfully expensive but it's still it's
still pretty pretty hard to hard to pay
the cost sometimes but if we can it's
got lots of benefits among them being
that every node and edge and your model
has a semantics probabilistic semantics
which helps you design a model that
takes the best advantage of your data
helps you figure out what your model is
doing debug it when something goes wrong
on the other hand unless you've been
living under a rock there are deep nets
and they are much faster at least
naively because they work basically
they're inference process is a whole
bunch of simple matrix operations fixed
you know quickly computed nonlinear
functions and the training as well can
be very fast right it's basically
stochastic gradient descent as opposed
to Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithms
that are harder to design and you know
may take a while to converge so not much
semantics necessarily in these things
but they're fast and they're very
successful and so the question I'm going
to ask in this talk is can we get the
best of both
right so can we design deep nets that
look more like graphical models or vice
versa
and take advantage of both the semantics
and the you know the scaling to scaling
to Big Data and so what we'd like is is
a model format that's both practical in
the sense of a deep nap right practical
you know you can train it quickly on
lots of data and get high performance
but we'd also like to import some of the
interpretation from from you know Bayes
rule so record I'm gonna take as an
example inference on a chain graph right
just a whole bunch of random variables
connected in a line and so for this
chain graph right if you know the
standard Bayes net is a hidden Markov
model but if you're a neural network
person you know forget about hidden
Markov models you're gonna use a
recurrent neural network maybe an LS TM
or a GRU or something like that
and I want to say that RNs are basically
Bayes Nets already so we're done the
talks over well not really but what do i
what do I mean that there's sort of
Bayes Nets already right so any if
you're if you're you know if you're a
recurrent neural network processing
along a sequence over time at any given
point you have to have a notion of what
the future is going to look like right
you have to be representing a
probability distribution over the future
and that's true no matter what your
architecture is because as long as
you're able to predict the next
observation you can then sample from
that distribution feed in your own
prediction and move yourself forward a
step and keep doing that until you have
a roll out of the future right so you're
representing implicitly a prediction
about the future which is you know
that's the the point of of a Bayes rule
is to give you a representation of that
distribution and the update rule for a
recurrent neural network right you
didn't learn it by Bayes rule you
learned it by let's say back prop
through time but if you learned it so
that it performs well it has to be
doing Bayes rule approximately right
otherwise you know I mean Bayes rule is
yeah the right answer so it has to be
doing approximately that so what we'd
like to do is make this implicit
representation more explicit in order to
maybe gain gain better performance and
behavior of these models so the first
step is that I'm going to suggest making
this implicit representation of the
future more explicit so in addition to
predicting your immediate next
observation the way an RNN would always
do I'm gonna suggest that you should
also predict statistics of the future so
things like you know moments of the next
few observations or the count of you
know the number of observations out of
the next ten that are all one or things
like that and if we have enough features
right just if you keep adding on
independent predictions that you have to
make by the time you know after some
point you're gonna get that your
predictions are a one-to-one map from
your latent state right so your your
latent state vector of your R and n
uniquely determines your predictions and
your predictions if there are enough of
them uniquely determine the latent state
vector and therefore they're also a 1:1
map from this probability distribution
that we're trying to represent and so
this this representation of a bunch of
predictions of expected statistics of
the future I'm gonna call this a
predictive state a state because it's a
1:1 map from your actually latent state
and predictive because it's a bunch of
predictions so this idea sounds simple
but it turns out to be powerful so just
a little intuition one example I like to
use as a video of a clock with its
pendulum swinging back and forth right
if you wanted to make a predictive state
you could directly predict the next two
frames of this video right and those two
frames would encode the state of the
clock in the sense that they would give
you enough to determine the position and
velocity of the pendulum which is the
physical state of the system
so that's a visual example for people
who like examples in equations let's say
we have a hidden Markov model so we have
a transition matrix T and an observation
matrix oh and we look at the expected
next observation given a current state
so that's the observation matrix times
the latent state the but next
observation one time in the future is
the is o times T times your state more
more steps in the future you keep
including more copies of T and if you
stack enough of them right if you stack
enough of them so that that matrix has
full column rank which you can always do
if there's if you don't have excess
useless states in your in your hidden
Markov model if you have enough of that
then that vector of predictions is a
predictive state so just the expected
observation over the next few time steps
so you can add this sort of predictive
state to a recurrent neural network and
doing so you know there's no necessary
reason that it has to make things better
it's an inductive bias it's a statement
about the problems we expect to
encounter but empirically it seems to
help prediction accuracy right so the
graph I have here is from from this
paper by Venkata meant at all it's drew
bag Nell's group where if you use a
particular algorithm for generating a
recurrent prediction in this case of an
action and a reinforcement learning
problem you get one level of quality and
if you add as well this predictive state
notion and train it to optimize that
this is an example of multi task
learning and it makes this this
inductive bias makes your performance go
up alright oh but there's a problem
right it's still a recurrent neural
network when you train it it's still
gonna get you probably to a local
optimum right so I've heard a lot of
people claimed that neural networks and
stochastic gradient have the the nice
property that all local optima are
approximately global but the one
exception well there may be more
exceptions but one certain exception to
that is recurrent networks it
is very very possible in my experience
to get into a very bad local optimum
when you're training a recurrent neural
network okay so what are we gonna do to
try and fix that so I'm gonna propose
that we should try and bootstrap from
supervised learning so empirically all
of the people making these claims that
all local optima are Global are talking
about supervised learning problems or at
least many of them are and empirically
it's true there seem to be fewer worries
about local optima when you're training
a supervised neural network and
theoretically it's also true like for
example if you have a linear predictor a
recurrent one can have local optima but
a supervised one cannot alright and so
let's try and borrow that property so
the bootstrap is gonna look work like
this we're gonna predict our future
features directly from a fixed window of
history instead of recurrently so that's
gonna be a supervised learning problem
right at any given time step you have a
past in the future and you predict the
future from the past but it's suboptimal
because you have a finite window of
memory right you can't remember anything
for longer than the length of that
window so that's step one step two now
I've got a bunch of predictions of the
future and I'm gonna take my prediction
that I made of the future at time T and
I'm gonna add that as an input when I
predict the future at time t plus 1
right so I'm gonna chain my predictions
together and this allows infinite memory
because a given observation will
influence my prediction and that
prediction can then influence the next
prediction and the next one and the next
one and so it sounds like I'm making
things recurrent again but I want to
emphasize that I'm fix I'm using past
predictions right I used an earlier
version of my model to make some
predictions I'm adding those to my
training set and they're fixed so I'm
not back propagating through them so
I've gotten rid of recurrence but I've
introduced a new problem which is that
the training distribution changes across
iterations right if my model changes
then my predictions change which changes
now because my predictions are input at
the next time step
I've changed my training distribution
and so I've broken the assumptions of
most supervised learning algorithms and
so step three is going to be to fix that
problem
and we're gonna fix that problem using
imitation learning so a quick detour
inference you can think of it as a very
special Markov decision process a very
special reinforcement learning problem
where the state is the predictions we've
made so far our action is to make
another prediction tack it on to the end
of our list of predictions and our cost
is the sum of the errors we make in the
predictions and so learning to do
inference is the same as finding a good
policy in this reinforcement learning
problem but the nice thing is that this
is not a general reinforcement learning
problem we actually have an expert if we
have training data that does a pretty
good job that gives us a good policy to
start from and what that expert does is
every time the expert is called on to
make a new prediction it copies that
prediction from from our training set
right and so that expert is a good
policy and so reinforcement learning
when you start with a good policy is
actually much easier it's you know
provably impossible in some sense if you
don't and provably possible in a sense
if you do and in particular we can
reduce imitation learning to supervised
learning which was the visitor autumn
from before we wanted to be able to
bootstrap off of supervised learning so
it's going to do that by a framework
called approximate policy iteration this
captures a number of different imitation
learning algorithms so for those of you
who haven't seen it exact policy
iteration in your reinforcement learning
problem you look at every single state
in action so you should already see a
problem with this right exact policy
iteration requires you to loop over all
states and actions in your problem
calculate some statistics of the of the
current policy how well it performs
starting from each state action pair and
some quantities you can compute from
those including the advantage which is
the difference between the quality of a
given action at a given state and the
quality of the best action at that state
and so we choose then a policy which
switches to the best action the policy
which optimizes the advantage meaning
the policy which
picks the action which has the smallest
difference from the best action namely
the best action at every state now this
doesn't work in a real size problem
because you can't iterate over all state
action pairs you can't exactly calculate
the advantage function you have to
estimate it somehow and you can't freely
choose a new policy right so I I just
said that my new policy I you know
separately said it value at every state
but I can't do that I have to work in
some hypothesis class of policies so
instead we're going to use approximate
policy iteration so to do that what
we're going to do is effectively
approximate each of the steps of policy
iteration instead of exactly computing
this advantage we're going to estimate
the advantage function and instead of
exactly computing this new policy we're
going to update our policy within some
hypothesis class to improve a criteria
and the same criterion we were trying to
improve before which is I just want to I
just want to highlight so what we want
is the expected value under the if we
follow the new policy and we look at the
states and actions we see when we're
following that new policy of the
advantage that we see of that state
action pair so we want to we want to
effectively reduce the number of times
we're taking suboptimal actions in a
given state and reduce the amount by
which they're suboptimal and so to
instantiate this so this is a meta
algorithm it's not you can't code it in
Python or or ray or any of these systems
without without saying how we're gonna
estimate the advantage and how we're
gonna do the update but supposing that
you could implement it you would get
some nice guarantees I'm not going to go
through the not going to go through the
the analysis but basically what it says
is that so this here this expectation is
what you're trying to optimize and if
you're able to get it below zero then
you're guaranteed that your new policy
is better than the old one and that's
something that you can empirically
measure so you know when you're
succeeding and sort of qualitatively
you'll see
seed when you have a policy that's not
the best in your class right you can't
expect to improve it if you already have
the best if the class is rich enough
that it can represent an improvement and
basically training succeeds that you're
actually able to find within your
hypothesis class this policy that causes
an improvement so a couple there are a
couple of specific algorithms within
this within this class that I wanted to
point out so one of them is called
dagger I just wanted to point out this
is not the same as the dagger that Mike
presented I also wanted to point out I
think we got the name first so anyway
but but we capitalized the first two
letters so you can tell the difference
between the algorithms so it stands for
data set aggregation and so the
algorithm it's the the details aren't
important
except that what you wind up doing is
solving a classification problem on
every iteration using what's called a no
regret learner so no regret learners are
a very nice if you're interested in
machine learning theory you should read
up on them they're kind of cool but the
key thing to know about them is that
neural nets are not one of them
and so what this lets you do is if
you're willing to restrict yourself to
the class of no regret learners this
gives you a way that that has some nice
results you can prove about the
improvement in the policy so the other
one I wanted to point out is instead of
completely solving this classification
problem using a no regret learner it's
also possible to write an algorithm that
does a gradient step you know much like
SGD but with a slightly different rule
for your calculating the gradient of
something else and so we another catchy
acronym for this one's called aggravated
differentiable
that's the d version of aggregate values
to imitate one of my collaborators has
an excel
of fondness of good acronyms as you can
probably tell from the past two slides
anyway so the point here is that you
don't have to restrict yourself with
this newer version of the algorithm to a
no regret learner you can do it with any
differentiable learner any any learner
where you can make a gradient descent
update step and so in both of these
cases what we've done is we've taken a
supervised learner and we've used it to
we've we've trained our neural network
not by back propagation through time not
as a recurrent neural network but by
reduction to a supervised learning
algorithm and empirically this actually
seems to help so the print is probably
too small to see but you know for
example on this this plot here this is
what you there's a baseline with Randa
so if you start from random
initialization you train several
different algorithms and they all get up
to some level of performance and then
for example this green line is the
vanilla version of the algorithm that I
just described and it it it's able you
know you you start with a smart
initialization and you can do more
gradient descent to get yourself better
and it winds up in a better local
optimum all right so how much time do I
have left I'm done okay so in that case
I think I will I'll stop here and just
summarize and say that basically what
I'm what I'm trying to do is to figure
out how to take these deep networks that
are so efficient so useful in practice
and make them bolt on semantics that's
more like a graphical model and to try
and gain some benefit from doing that
not just the benefit of interpretability
but benefits in actual practical
performance as well so thank you
but request all our speakers to actually
come up and then if anyone in the
audience has questions please raise your
hands we have mic runners here we'll get
a mic to you all right what do you want
us to stand in the spotlight of course
so as as we're figuring this out as to
questions from the audience maybe I can
start off I had question about strong
guarantees so it looks like there is
this trend finally we've reached a point
where they're programming their tools
including you know programming language
support that will allow us to whole
programs responsible for what they're
doing right strong guarantee strong
programs there's always been this move
model checking in systematic testing but
now verification in terms of a proof so
you know you fail at the compile step as
opposed to you know running your program
and now all of sudden gear hit with this
wave of you know models that can
potentially replace programs they're
learning from samples it's not clear of
these samples you know it's not clear
how robust they are right so is this
taking us back a step we've taken we've
just began to take a step forward and
are we going to be taking a step back do
you have an you know an opinion on this
yeah we push back against software 2.0 I
mean I think it's it's not a replacement
of software 1.0 at all it's just a
different tool so it's a commodity you
can get a neural net to learn how to
maybe recognize certain class of image
the visual scenes and say there's a
person that never not you can do that
with software to point out other words
gather all the data of all possible
scenes and all possible people and put
them into a big neural in the head and
make it better and better over the years
and ship that okay but that thing has
done no product no abstraction it's not
a real it's not a predictable module for
all purposes it's just a little pizza so
it's like an accelerator so I don't
think of it as replacing there all that
said if you know static run Hispanic
versus dynamic
don't think dynamic is the way to go
it's not gonna see all the things that
can happen in the real world we had our
face to the real world a static program
you know you can and you can prove that
the things could do exactly the thing
you hope to do but what you're hoping to
do is exactly wrong so you get a great
proof that it's gonna it's gonna do the
wrong thing so no I think it's all about
in computer science I've got to realize
that the next wave is interfacing with
the real world with all of its vagaries
and not proving that what happens inside
the computer is what you thought would
happen so I think there's some there's
some really exciting work that's going
on at Stanford from dorsa who just came
over and other folks are working on
validation and verification sort of they
call themselves the AI safety group but
trying to say even if you have a black
box view of what's going on under these
two covers can you do higher-level
ferrant sort of proofs on it so Michael
Corcoran Dorfler who actually worries
about planes turning left right and
center actually has some pretty exciting
stuff where he's able to say yes indeed
you know we can verify that the plane
when it's claimed it's going to turn
left for control three will turn lat
so that's one issue so there are a whole
host of places where people have paid
the cost for verification to build
software products for a long period of
time but the trend seems to be going
kind of the other way in my mind I mean
when Python first came around but
everyone said oh it doesn't have types
it doesn't catch anything at compile
time no one's going to use it but the
amount of stuff that's built on top of
it is truly staggering right and so you
know as mike says and I agree the pieces
that people are building right now with
these neural nets they are kind of these
individual components but those
individual components and those
individual functional teams are building
most of the applications that are being
built at the hyper scalars and so I
think in one way when we're in agreement
is we need abstractions to be able to
compose those things and understand them
and validate what's going on we need
some notion of modularity but I think
it's a new notion of modularity it's not
the traditional like software 1.0 wasn't
that great right it's not like we solved
all these problems and didn't have bugs
and understood what was going on it was
kind of a show I think is the
technical term so you know the
comparison of the bar is pretty low so
that I think the interesting question
and we're we probably are in agreement
is okay we have these great pattern
matching engines they allow us to do
certain tasks that are you know just too
difficult to program kind of tediously
you know line by line
do we build them into realistic systems
that don't fall over in the wild and
right now we have machine learning
systems that are deployed that make
stupid errors day in day out hundreds of
times a day where you can't imagine why
they get that wrong so we got to do
something there and I think Mike's
Mike's right it's probably going to be
some amount of abstraction of how do we
program these things but you're no
longer programming like jumps in for
loops and things like that your program
at a much higher level of abstraction
and it's a challenge for you know
computer science to get there my my
phone fails to autocomplete my name
every time a lot recently yeah really
yeah pretty simple yeah so I I have to
agree with this idea that abstraction is
gonna be the really important thing and
I don't think we're there yet I don't
think we know the right way that AI
systems are gonna do abstraction that
you're gonna be able to compose AI
systems with one another and I think
this is you know it's a grand frontier
for research because I think there are a
bunch of really interesting ideas out
there but nobody's solved it are the
questions in the audience
someone's waving at me telling me we're
out of time but I have one question so
this is about sort of benchmarks so it
looks like you know there are lot of
algorithms new algorithms people are
coming up with highlighting their
awesomeness including new hardware that
people are coming up with and people
have big and big the baby steps of
defining benchmarks so that you know
there can be some common substrate you
know that you can use for comparison so
you might you might have heard of ml
birth right as being an example where
they're collating a bunch of models
working models that different people can
actually use to to as a benchmark but
that's just a first small step do you
have thoughts and what the benchmark
should look like what's missing in there
that that ought to be there from like an
entering perspective and not just
individual algorithms like image
classification one thing I'll plug there
is Matteo Aria and Peter Bayliss did a
huge amount of work on dawn bench which
came out and now is
moving in to be part of the m/l perf
effort and i think you know they had a
really a great vision there that I
understand about trying to hold people's
feet to the fire and understand how to
bring back that level of in a sort of
indirection or abstraction that allows
people to optimize models independently
of their applications I think Mike made
a great reference to this and I agree
the current set of end-to-end models is
kind of a disaster because you can't
work on one component without affecting
every other component and so benchmarks
are one way to potentially drive like
okay we're gonna understand this level
you know I haven't given it as much
thought as those folks you should
definitely ask Matteo I think he's
giving a talk in the in the next session
he's thought about this a lot more
deeply but the current benchmarks are
kind of just the traditional horse races
right they're just hey this looks like a
spec benchmark we want to see how fast
do we go there's nothing about sample
efficiency there's nothing about data
augmentation you know there's just the
Inklings of what's going to be around
mobile performance which is a huge and
massive area that's that's something
that's coming online so benchmarking
that's closer to what people are
building is an obvious direction to go
and I think it's something I hope that
you know ml perf is one of many efforts
I hope it doesn't get controlled by just
corporations I assume had a great tweet
about exactly that point that academics
you know really should be playing a
bigger role and kind of being neutral
arbiters of hey here's what's
interesting and exciting and Matt and
Peter deserve a lot of credit for for
going out there and doing a lot of
unglamorous work to get that thing
running so on that no I think like
benchmarks are important terms are
defining the workload but also in terms
of defining what are the metrics that
people should actually be measuring I
think often there's a lot of games that
can be played in terms of let's say
you're running the same net but whether
or not you batch or not batch whether or
not you're designing how much do you
rely on off chip memory on ship memory
thinking more from the mobile side of
things it's really important to give a
comprehensive set of metrics to validate
those particular benchmark so not just
the workload but what are the metrics
that should be evaluated as well shelf
will be incorporated yeah I
first of all just need to emphasize
again this is not one little field this
is not data basis this is huge huge it's
all about everything having to do with
you know all of a be testing is included
in here all of control theory is
included you know all of
natural language processing you know
just this is massive and so there's not
going to can't be a few benchmarks so
with Chris I totally agree on this looks
like it's good if there's a need for a
lot of them in lots of further testing
various various aspects or but and I
agree with her - it's all since it is
about not just what's inside the
computer it's about what's in the real
world the loss functions should be
things that people care about so they
should have utilities there so they
should be worried about dangers that you
could get into the situation and get it
I mentioned provenance early and we just
kind of bring that back out a little bit
you know database people are the only
ones I know about who really talk about
this and I think they have so much more
they could do with it because you know
provenance is that you know a piece of
data should be tagged with where it was
you know what was found in what you know
as various metadata about it in a
statistical setting it's question is how
relevant is it so you're a doctor and
trying to decide a treatment for me well
you look around is there any other
people I've ever seen like this person
alright that's Providence and how
relevant is that date I collect on that
person and that person's living over
there and you know in Africa is that
relevant or is it there that that whole
collection of issues is relevant for a
decision at a particular context that's
Providence broadly writ and so thinking
about the benchmarks for that I can't
you know it's very hard but it's the key
part it's a it's a key part it's one of
a hundred key parts of the problem so
yes we got to be quantitative and all
that but let's definitely not get to a
few benchmarks and have them be neural
nets you know to apply to images too
soon because that would really kill off
the bigger picture and one thing I
should also plug in there which is on
this thing is there's a great paper by
Percy Liang and his co-authors Percy's
amazing is about like sort of where QA
systems kind of went awry right so
there's a squad benchmark that people
put out I mean Percy something might
suit some history he did this whole
thing about squad with Pranava and then
it got kind of gamed to no end
and so if Percy and click the click
through rate has gotten game where our
society is suffering from it so you know
definitely nothing about real metrics
that matter to human beings out there he
published a paper that's an ACL that I
would advise checking out about how you
can fool these systems and how they
don't exhibit any of the kind of
understanding no matter you know
anonymous corporations putting out
beating human level metrics I won't say
which one
but but I think that that that sort of
introspection only happens with a
benchmark so you could view it as
negative and say Oh
poopoo the benchmark but actually a
drove a huge amount of work and said oh
actually the interesting challenge is
over here and forced researchers to say
hey I thought all these features were
important they didn't show up at all in
performance but this robustness thing is
really you know the place where we need
to focus on so I think these benchmarks
are gonna play an outsized role and are
really empirical science now going
forward I think that's right I think you
have to think of a benchmark not as a
fixed target but as a way to discover
the next benchmark right that as soon as
you figure out how to cheat the first
benchmark that guys exactly designing a
second one right so I guess we're over
time if people have questions please
continue the discussion in the break so
I think the next session starts at 3:00
let's thank our speakers once again
[Applause]